Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg is calling
for stricter regulation of the web
Facebook wants new regulations
Mark Zuckerberg wrote an op-ed that said
lawmakers often tell me we have too much
power over speech and frankly I agree we
shouldn't make so many important
decisions on our own Wow
it sounds so self-sacrificing but give
me a break
big companies tend to like regulation
because it gives them an advantage over
smaller competitors after all startups
can't afford the squads of lawyers and
compliance officers that Facebook
employees in France they embedded
officials inside the company my position
is not that there should be no
regulation Zuckerberg issued his call
for regulation after spending hours
being grilled by members of Congress I
think the Internet is increasing in
embrace regulation I think the real
question as the Internet becomes more
important in people's lives is what is
the right regulation not whether there
should be you as a company welcomed
regulation I think if it's the right
regulation than you think
Zuckerberg is no dope he sees which way
the wind is blowing so would you work
with us in terms of what regulations you
think are necessary in your industry
absolutely so Facebook will work with
politicians to shape regulation what's
sad is that if anyone should fight for
permissionless innovation it should be
people like Mark Zuckerberg it's no
accident that's the amazing wealth
creation that brought us Facebook Google
Instagram Apple Microsoft Amazon
smartphones computers all happened in
the two big metropolitan areas farthest
from Washington DC Microsoft in the
early 1990s was the largest company in
the world incredibly successful and they
spent exactly zero dollars on lobbying
on cronyism on lawyers they had no
presence in Washington DC
not a single lawyer instead of spending
money on lawyers of lobbyists they spent
it on technology but once politicians
noticed their success they will
literally brought in front of Congress
they were yelled at by
a Republican Orrin Hatch from Utah he
said you guys need to get involved here
in Washington DC you need to build a
building here you need a hire lawyers
here in other words the unspoken text
you need to bribe me and Microsoft
walked out of the meeting and said you
know what you leave us alone we will
leave you alone we're busy we're running
the biggest company in the world
there's a lot to do the Justice
Department has charged Microsoft six
months later knocking the door at
Microsoft
we're from the Justice Department and
we're here to prosecute you because
you're offering the American public
offer your customers a product for free
this is Internet Explorer at a time when
we were buying Netscape and paying money
for it they offered it for free and that
was deemed you know bad business
practices there was a Hyneman duh
monopoly of trying to dominate the
market for 10 years there to fight that
lawsuit they lost they got regulated
they got controlled guess how much
Microsoft spends today in Washington DC
how much tens of millions of dollars
they have a beautiful building about
equal distance from the White House and
fun day for Congress they have lawyers
they have lobbyists they spend a lot of
money and indeed a lot of other tech
companies like Google learnt the lesson
the lesson is if you don't want
politicians destroying your business
practice self defense go to Washington
and give the money kiss their rings
making sure to keep politicians at bay
so a lot of the lobbying a lot of the
so-called cronyism is self defense yes
and Zuckerberg Zack ting in self defense
but it's still ugly and Silicon Valley's
crony capitalism is a threat to future
innovation but in fairness to Zuckerberg
he didn't start it but let's remember
what cronyism comes from cronyism occurs
when governments thoughts interfering in
business and then business has to defend
itself and as soon as it fires the
lawyers and the lobbyists to defend
itself it quickly slips in to now
gaining favors from the government who
has all this power if we really want to
end cronyism what we need to do is
reduce the power of politicians over our
lives actually separate economics from
state